so here for you now I don't know it for
a fact I just know it's true coronavirus
edition I don't know it for a fact that
quarantined self haircuts are better
than what you'd get at Fantastic Sams I
just know it's true I don't know it for
a fact that people are going to
their first tinder match after
conference II just know it's true I
don't know it for a fact that employees
at Sears have no idea there's been a
lockdown I just just know it's truth I
don't know it for a fact that the
Kardashians are deciding which sister to
sacrifice to the virus to stay relevant
oh that's very me that's kidding I don't
know for a fact that dr. Burks cries in
her car I just know it's true I don't
know for a fact that Melania tells Trump
not tonight it might be a symptomatic
they symptomatic something like that I
don't know what for a fact that Lou
Dobbs drinks his hotdog water but really
related to the crisis but sort of I
don't know what for a fact that you've
been through so many categories on
pornhub you're thinking of clicking on
the one where the chicks are giants but
see I've heard about that one I don't
know it for a fact that somewhere a
Jewish mother is complaining to her son
you never call you never zoom just know
that one's true I don't know for a fact
that your wife thinks about gavin newsom
during sex oh it's true and i don't know
for a fact that Bush would have
this up to not as bad but he would have
okay
you